we could be one step closer to covet
relief as the u.s house of
representatives passed a 1.9
trillion dollar package late last night
representative
susie lee spoke on the plan today saying
it could bring
our state some much needed support if it
passes with support from the senate
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
joins us live tonight to share what this
could mean for nevada
madison yes in tonight's town hall
congresswoman susie lee was laser
focused
on the covet relief package the new
package that is
and how it's going to help nevadans now
we're talking from you know unemployment
benefits to the new stimulus check
leaders really want to know how this is
going to benefit those that really need
it
good morning everyone a town hall was
held today via phone going over plans
for the 1.9
trillion pandemic relief package nevada
congresswoman susie lee led the
conversation with details on what this
new plan will bring
american rescue plan out of the house of
representatives
that included money to get shots in the
arms of americans
14 billion dollars we got a new round of
much-needed stimulus checks that will go
directly to nevada's families and also
we ensured that
expanded unemployment unemployment
benefits do not
expire they expanded the unemployment
benefits through the end of august with
additional benefits going from
300 dollars per week to 400. and 9.1
billion dollars will go to additional
funding for rental assistance
as for those next to get the vaccine one
woman who was a ride share driver wanted
to know if her line of work would be
included in the transportation tier
you know i come in contact with about
360 people
every week directly in my car so i
am definitely concerned about you know
myself
every single week and the answer was
encouraging as uber and lyft and other
ride share drivers are included
as for our public schools in clark
county congresswoman lee acknowledged
that our state has struggled with
overcrowding in our classrooms
and explains how these extra funds will
help nevada has struggled with
for years with our overcrowded
classrooms and underfunding of education
and i'm proud to report that this
package that we just passed
includes 130 billion dollars in direct
funding for k-12 education that will
help reduce
classify class sizes and modify spaces
so
that teachers and students can socially
distance this plan will bring
four billion dollars to nevada clark
county will receive 440 million dollars
with 131 million going to the city of
las vegas
and if this bill passes congresswoman
lee said about 3 billion dollars will go
to the state
whereas 1 billion will go to cities and
counties reporting live madison
kimbrough 8 news now